citizens of the reject Nation after months
of requests and since uh I'm out of town from
the 12th to the 20th I figured it's about
time we answered the call and I got my buddy
Aaron Alexander to join me today for this
r r r Aaron how are you I'm doing wonderful
I'm in the Christmas spirit
I have never seen a frame I've never seen
a clip a trailer a mini thing on YouTube I've
never seen anything about that have you I
haven't the slightest clue I have no idea
what we're walking into but I've been bombarded
forever to watch it so I was like all right
here we go gonna do it guys smash that like
button and as always full length three action
watch alongs where you sync up with your own
copy of RR available for our super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page we also covered exclusively
several shows over their reaction Heights
and watch alongs included I'll move reactions
you see here full length watch Longs over
there I hear it's exciting I've had people
at parties be like you should do RR so apparently
it's an exciting film no idea what we're going
to get into right now but let's see
[Music]
there's white people in this yeah I think
this is uh Brits uh it's amazing Who's the
artist I want to have this little package
on our mantelpiece Edward yes sir
okay there we go
[Applause] oh
Jesus
no do you comprehend the value of the bullet
in your Barrel it was manufactured in an English
Factory using English Metals it crossed the
seventh season in English vessel by the time
it reached the barrel of Yorkshire it cost
one pound one pound sterling and you would
want to squander it on Brown rubbish ouch
damn clear the road
[Music] oh Jesus oh my God oh why
oh wow the production design on this is gnarly
that's powerful [Music]
that's a great shot you should recruit this
guy arrest that buster bring him to me [Music]
got into the crowd rest that one guy [Music]
but throw down
oh my god oh dude
Mr Officer what are you doing [Applause]
ah
damn this guy's deal
it's a
claustrophobic wow he's in a man cave
oh oh my God he's gonna really make his way
out this crowd he's gonna he's gonna finish
that assignment
laughs
I think I want to understand is why is he
fighting so hard for the Brits I know
oh jeez Louise oh God [Music]
he's powered by Vengeance and good mustache
jeans oh
that's cool that's a beautiful shot the fire
is reflective of this man's passion [Music]
trouble then very good
why are those buckets labeled fire
oh [__]
to put out fires oh right back to his post
foreign
[Laughter]
contribution they are Philip Anderson Charles
Langford Frank Pooh you gotta be [__]
me wow
[Music]
The Swinging on that rope actually saved him
time no but it looked cool
yeah
damn there's some gnarly visuals
oh no no
that's awesome
foreign
[Laughter]
together you can do it
Flex like you've never flexed before
now you can really tie it together
actually knock it out oh my God just those
claws alone right
[Music] oh damn thing won't stop
removed something earlier and attached it
now so you can charge me again you cheating
bastard you have no idea who you're messing
with man we have a hunter to roaming free
we have nothing on him you mean nothing it's
quite an impossible task how the hell are
we supposed to catch him the one that accomplishes
The Impossible um will be promoted to the
rank of special officers where's my stash
boy do you want him dead or alive
there he is there's Mustache Boy are you hitting
him like that he's forgotten his ID mom that
doesn't give you the right can animals sorry
ma'am
is good she's beautiful
hey we're watching the ploy that he's playing
at
you
damn wow how are they doing a shot super drone
well he's somewhere in that region [Laughter]
oh that's not good
holy God Jesus
it's going to hit that child whoa
foreign [Music]
[Music]
[Music] nope I don't have the
slightest clue
[Music]
okay
cool
yikes awesome hell yeah he's gonna catch him
with the flag oh they're gonna trade
[Music] oh dope
[Music] cool [Laughter] [Music]
oh God that will last forever this is just
the beginning
hey rise for revolt
Brothers [Laughter] oh my God they're gonna
work together yeah I thought they're gonna
fight this is better
[Music] I mean he's got to be like trying
to work his way up the ranks in some way to
get he must have some type of vet and data
mission right seems that way
I love this friendship is if you don't squat
you're homie you're not really friends
[Music]
bang the white lady bang the colonizer
two motorcycles we're gonna throw these needles
at her get her attention yeah throw them playground
rules here just be really mean to her proper
tires I think they're gonna do that yeah yeah
[Laughter] we're such Rascals you're just
gonna pop some tires for fun [Music]
they watch as 10 men mugger [Laughter] instead
of put it in a terrible yeah
it's the perfect plan
[Laughter]
North poor tram station nearby huh
oh are you going that way
[Music] I'm sorry I can't understand what
you're saying he wants to go inside your home
and make a love to you and you have his children
passionately oh don't call me memsaab it's
just Jenny yes
[Music] Jenny yes [Music] just Jenny is
[Laughter] it it's not for me there is a small
girl staying with us Molly [Laughter] I love
the music dude
foreign
what's he about to make oh a bracelet
wow that was really fast [Music] how beautiful
she's going to love it there is a party at
the Gymkhana Club hmm yeah baby please do
try to come
bye you will learn English in the next few
hours I will study diligently Aaron will also
learn English I will fix it before [Laughter]
a bangle [Music] it's a clue hell yeah
they go uh Feb 14th it's Valentine's Day if
you're in need of a dance partner Jennifer
you need to look any further I'm your perfect
looking at the best dance around him I second
that oh dorky isn't how small he is um let's
join the party you bought carry on I'll join
you in a while a pipe I love how this whole
movie he was full of Fury until he met him
a guy he's neither bro yeah would you like
to dance oh this is where you speak the love
language oh he knows how to dance you have
no idea he's about to make a literal hole
in that dance floor baby I run from tigers
in the jungle yeah I Dance with the Devil
I'm sorry
[Music] oh no you hurt a white woman
whatever dance off oh snap oh dang let's get
this [__] on the road man let's go let's
go
show them up show them up come on can you
do
it break dance [Music]
[Laughter] yeah yeah baby go [Music] let's
go support your brother hunting [Music] it
always starts with the Bob not salsa not Flamenco
my brother do you know Desi Notch homie's
so Suave dude
yes hell yeah hey
yes look at him go look at him go hey
yes look at him Joe
oh they are perfectly safe [Laughter] this
is the best
Series
this song right
can't hang homie
what are they gonna do what are they gonna
do
yes oh my God hey
blues for her lose Elevate him elevate your
brother don't [__] block him
which is what he does with the tiger oh we
can go home now
why don't you carry me like that you know
what
he's got a bad cramp can you drop him at a
new buzzer of course of course yeah they're
barely even sweating would you like to come
to my place it's almost so much like Roseburg
before I drop you home
Molly
yo you've lost sight of the mission the prize
man there's a oh my God he's about to put
together right now oh please don't put it
together right now right in this moment
wait how was it got the color of the thing
is
[Music] that's not our guy no no but it's
the first guy who um earlier in the movie
when he was chasing him yeah yeah when they're
at the gate oh there's that anger there's
that Fury open the gate [Music]
be cool man be cool servants could not use
the main entrance man he is not a servant
friend let him go
As You Wish ma'am can't wait for these people
to die [Laughter]
[Music] I'll break it down you know how to
do it
[Music] foreign
jungle
oh [__] oh no
it's got beautiful fingernails oh it's really
confused there for a second I was like he's
really nice
you did mention that this must be this must
be his backstory to it somehow this will get
him back to her right as this has got to be
the reason why he's doing this the real question
snake get me out of here snake come on come
on snake bro snake bite through this for heaven's
snake get me out of here
got him that was really good timing man hiker
today [Music] whoa whoa damn oh damn
he got him
it's pretty calm about this [Music] oh no
notice him oh you got me [__] me noticing
oh it's frustrating jungle
gotta go back hi
he's got a great run [Music]
foreign
damn
together oh no [Music]
uh you better remember this all right when
you're fine
foreign
[Music] you're fighting the wrong guy
oh poor guy
[Music]
oh my God I thought they were sneaking right
nope oh they are no snake eat it here
I did not see that coming this is like some
original Jungle Book [__] right here all
right [Music] go spread murder
murder Mayhem
no wrong person
[Music]
yo this movie is bastardly added yeah very
well done there's like 4 million shots slap
the [__] out of it that's what I'm talking
about oh it's right whip him how does it feel
does it feel to be whipped by chains huh how
does it feel I like the way you scream
Jesus
[Applause] yep our boy it's our other boy
no it's like Revelations up in here
oh come on is he back to the stash come on
man he's a man of the mission you both didn't
know he's like freaking Four Horsemen
[Music] um
oh my god oh come on surrender
Ken he really can't look him in the eyes huh
[Music] oh my God oh my God [Music]
oh here we go
Jesus oh my God oh my God go for the kill
shot of there
whoa whoa [Applause]
damn this is amazing choreography
damn that's an epic ass shot
it's like Mortal Kombat over here this is
so sick
ouch oh my God how is this foot more powerful
than
do it you know you can't do it you love them
you also can't bring him in dad remember [Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me that is so messed
up
instead of bringing bad luck [Music] [Applause]
jeez what a shot oh my God the blood infection
doing that man hey Rama Raju is being awarded
the rank of special officer got what you wanted
hope you're happy was it worth it Raju they'll
squats me nothing squatted you man you dance
together
[Music] oh now it's a flashback yes I know
[Laughter] tomorrow oh my god did he send
his son in there to be like the ultimate undercover
guy [Music] um foreign
[Music]
oh my God what that turned so fast
we scared him sir thank God
yikes got him in the finger and the back
yeah baby show them how it's done [Music]
oh no no no no no no no no no no no oh you
gotta be kidding me you [__] [__]
no no oh no
Lord
[Music]
okay I'm gonna leave him there it is
oh in the face
[Music] got it yeah she's playing a real long
game here yeah
exactly yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
of Daring to rise against us and begs for
Mercy this music is great too no
it's really come this far
foreign
Jesus lady
oh he's making him Bend he didn't kneel
she has to die first
oh he was making sure it didn't Neil officer
[__] Passion of the Christ [Music]
come all right so you gotta be motivated in
some way [Music] Jesus Christ
damn oh [__] oh my God that's awful rise
[Music] there we go yep it is didn't realize
it they're wanted to make an example out of
it and the opportunities give more fuel
foreign
[Music] yes and what was blatantly obvious
was your abject failure at bringing this brute
to his knees I'm sorry sir
[Music] what did you do we'll find out it'll
come in handy right
okay perfectly slid that in there
very good it's a fascinating world it's like
starting to question the rules like this but
the movie imagined to be like so serious too
go faster
I said faster damage
oh [__] yeah oh he's gonna grab that gun
isn't it here damn [Music] what the hell what
the [__]
you gotta be kidding me no no [Music] foreign
[Music]
oh [__] face smashes on these men all
right it's brutal man
oh [__]
[Music]
oh it's not what you think it is homie
no [Music]
oh he has no idea
oh no no oh next to his head next to his head
right he'll be so starving he'll be gnoring
at his chains
[Music] that's what I'm talking about yeah
damn okay well I'm in a solitary cell
[Music] ouch
yes get it
to everyone [Music] oh [__] she came over
here in
foreign
[Music]
shoot
oh my God really sacrificed himself huh
damn that is a haunting memory right there
to kill his own dad [__] man but he became
a great dancer along the way
not if he can stop it
gotta save his boy in return
he's dancing the pattern the Rhythm yes
[Music]
Brothers yeah
let's do this [Music]
fight is one
go oh my God it's so sick crap that's incredible
yes do it man yes
they're one Superman oh [__] oh cool yes
it's gnarly yes I love it I love it so much
[Music] this is awesome oh my God oh
yeah go yay
oh my God they're becoming a centipede
he's gonna flip him up there oh yes yes they've
just had no [__] yeah one shot that's
what we're talking about my man
hahaha
this is so insane so creative [Music]
yes I love it I love it oh man
[Music] he just knows an herb for every situation
you don't even know where he's at dude
oh it's so sickness
hell yeah
oh
oh holy God
[Music]
yikes right in the jugular
sick wow that's beautiful yeah though you
saw the bridge scene yeah they don't need
words shoot hey
nice
oh
no [__] way that's what I'm talking about
it's like What's it gonna do are we just gonna
grab it all right all right [Music]
ah the reprisal hell yeah look at them go
I love that twist under the the horse that
was amazing
yes Ghost Rider
this is TNT oh yeah
amazing oh they're destroying the British
Empire oh my God
why'd you go inside when did you go inside
he's trying to get guns for everyone it's
a little too late for that man
is that my blood he's moving oh this hurts
your sadistic wife is dead sucks too so whoa
she's like covered in the barbed wires and
everything
the weapons for all the villages
yes
oh the bullet bullets the bullet Lord
oh
this is great this is so cathartic this is
great
[Music]
I love that they're the best the greatest
chemistry
ah they finally get to be together
friendship
[Laughter]
[Music]
he really does look like a warrior I mean
he pulls off the long hair really well it
pulls his full of every look he's had in this
you know Screw you man you can look like both
it's not fair it pulls up both looks too well
oh yeah her story right here yeah a little
focus on rap stories she's gotta get her back
home that's right [Music]
beautiful wonderful
all right wow okay I'll listen to Netflix
I'll just watch something else now but on
Wednesday
just keep it rolling same video three hours
why don't you just watch something else bullet
trains only on Netflix what that was awesome
dope dope let's talk about it after I go to
the bathroom really alrighty okay well didn't
look up anything in that bathroom [Laughter]
breaks I've hit a record we're going we just
went so blind with this I was like keep it
blind keep it blind just go from here uh it
was fascinating going into this because like
I said I hadn't seen like a a frame of this
movie before watching it but you know the
talk I always heard was like this film was
crazy this film's wild you gotta watch this
movie it's crazy and so my preconceived notions
before watching it were that it's like it's
just going to be three hours of just insane
visuals and action scenes from beginning to
end like this is what I thought based off
the way everyone described the experience
of this movie and to me I'm like well it's
not that at all like I mean like they have
their sequences that are like crazy you know
that don't get me wrong they have secrets
that are like so visually expression it and
insane and enthralling like obviously like
without a doubt but it's not this like non-stop
chaotic thing that the way how people have
sort of like talked this movie up in that
regard doesn't like this movie is actually
a lot deeper than than anyone like no one
literally nobody no and when you heard about
this wasn't it that's not like mainly what
you would hear like this movie was crazy it's
like three hours of the non-stop actions they
go long stretches without action they go like
very long stretches I could probably count
on like like a couple of hands and I heard
nobody talk about the dancing yeah that's
true I mean it's a Bollywood movie so I guess
you would expect that but I've never seen
and my brother jabby Coy obviously very much
in that whole International Market but this
is my first um I think this is my first feature
film out of and I'm afraid to get this wrong
because I know a lot of times you get these
regions all messed up and it can offend him
and we don't intend to just look at this as
dumb Americans okay um but yeah the a first
Indian movie Bollywood film ever experienced
uh me personally you yourself too so I've
never watched one before not for camera or
just in my own life so they must all be the
same and they must all be this way right right
all of them are three hours long and they're
all exactly like this biggest Market in all
in the in the entertainment field yeah um
but no I mean for a first time experience
with that I thought it was a lot deeper than
because it deals so much with the anti-colonialism
and Grand like my history is not the sharpest
when it comes to this stuff but you know it
you can pick up on it even if you're not super
familiar with it obviously dealing with the
the British Empire rule and then it's it's
a story about overcoming oppression and coming
together and also you know you have these
two guys on uh who are fighting for the same
cause anti-colonialism they're fighting for
the same cause and they you know one's more
tribal and one's more westernized culture
uh indoctrinated into it and then by the end
of it it's like they learn through the Revolutionary
Ways and through the causes that it's kind
of have to be a blend of both well they're
revolting you know and I think it was kind
of a really cool personal story I think I
did hear forever ago because we were saying
this in between filming that it might you
made it joke is it based on a true story but
I actually heard him it might be based on
a true story I did hear that like it must
be inspired by something true because obviously
like it seems like historically like I don't
know exactly what in that final dance number
everyone it's showcasing I don't know anyone
they're really showcasing there because yeah
my history on the on that side is is not that
large um but obviously it was like this must
be in reference to real life people you know
these must be real life people and uh who
who did stand up against all this [__]
they had to deal with but it is so much more
than just bang bang cool sweet visuals and
it's neat to get a movie that has so much
of uh about like real life War themes happening
throughout but then also to combine it with
some of that 80s like action cheese in a way
that looks super sweet so yeah man yeah dude
I just think that we talked you talked a lot
about how everyone talked about how crazy
it was in terms of action I think the thing
that surprised me the most was how much hard
it had and the relationship between the two
main characters I never I've not seen a bromance
that strong in a movie and I don't know how
long and you know it was really heartbreaking
watching these two guys come to head because
you're just even though there's a song at
the beginning of the movie that kind of foretells
the things are gonna happen even when it is
happening you're just like no you guys are
so great together you guys just had a dance
number and you like you do squats and and
you're riding motorcycle that came back around
like at the beginning this is like it's just
kind of funny and then it comes into playing
the in the big rescue scene yeah hilarious
and it's badass and yeah man I think it really
told a story and it really made you dislike
and have like a a bitter resentment towards
the the British and the and anticholonialism
and I think that watching these two guys come
together in the end super satisfying in spite
of the fact that you know I for the most part
I didn't really feel the run time I was just
kind of super invested in everything that
was going on and yeah like three hours no
it didn't feel like three hours I'm like two
and a half that's exactly yeah but yeah dude
I think that you know I what really made the
movie for me was like the music the music
and the sound design was incredible in this
the stunt work was incredible in this movie
like all of the the different wire work and
how creative they were with the action scenes
it was like yeah it's you can tell that I
think it was a what my takeaway is like great
action and great storytelling is international
it's made everywhere Grant obviously I've
we've both watched foreign films on this channel
before I don't watch as many foreign films
as I would like to uh in my personal life
but I think doing stuff like this with Greg
really kind of opens my eyes up to the different
types of of film that's out there you know
and the way they they utilize the camera and
the way that they utilize slow motion to uh
to kind of elevate their storytelling and
yeah just you see that they Infuse both their
culture with this uh with the way that they
elevated their characters for example like
the the dancing scene with them having the
dance off so he's kind of wing Manning so
his boy can get the girly at the end of the
day and I was just like I thought that was
a very clever use of using something that's
traditional in more Indian films to kind of
I don't know Grand I don't know if how they're
used in other films but I was just like that's
that's [__] smart I like that yeah uh
yeah I think there's just a lot of really
clever uses of of uh all the things all the
stuffs yeah oh yeah super no it's a massive
technical achievement in in every regard because
like cinematography wise everything really
pops it's gorgeous it looks like it was filmed
on like IMAX cameras or something because
you can see that the way that I I really love
IMAX cameras and there's Parts about it that
felt like did they shoot this on on that type
of HD lens um but yeah the everything really
popped and it is very imaginative and it is
so many different styles and tones all meshed
into one yeah and it flows uh it's kind of
like a very different movie but I would use
similar nouns and adjectives to describe is
like everything everywhere all at once yup
like this is wild and I've never seen anything
quite like it and it's a bunch of different
things on a big blender and somehow it all
communicates well and I'm never laughing at
the movie you know exactly and I and I felt
some kind of a similar experience here you
know and especially to get that that Bollywood
dance number when um beam is with uh Jenny
and and then they go into the Bollywood dance
number I thought that was such a a beautifully
executed sequence and you felt like you felt
like to pump me up about it you know because
it took me a little bit of time to be like
okay what exactly is this movie what exactly
where exactly is this going but when they
do come together when they do like touch Brothers
in Arms you know like it's about how they
have to unite together and embrace their different
parts of where they come from within the same
hemisphere here that that is the thing that
could lead to Conquest over this oppression
and so that's the journey like that's a deeper
part of this journey you know and I think
it's kind of a beautiful story like there's
it's actually a beautiful story in a lot of
ways so I get why this resonated so much more
Beyond just like it's a big Indian film like
it it seemed to really make its way over to
here and I was kind of surprised just because
I I've never heard of it and I never even
saw a trailer for it but seeing what this
movie is now I'm like no I could get it because
you know we've we have our own dealings with
uh with Wars in history and I feel like themes
about anti-colonialism and oppression and
and overcoming the racism and all that like
all those things we've I think that's a universal
thing as much as this is very specifically
tied to the Indian culture and the history
those subjects and feelings that can be a
very Universal uh attainable feeling that
we all can sort of connect to in some way
shape or form and I think this movie really
hits that Mark Strong because they keep it
as an intimate story between the two of them
and I love the arc like I really like beam
a lot like he's great he kind of reminds me
of an anime character yeah just like this
who's ever like shocked by things like every
time he's like a reveal happens you know an
anime character is always like
whenever something yeah you'd make a great
reaction Channel um yes but um the IMDb is
kind of confused you have IMDb full in front
of us I thought his name was RAM for the subtitles
wrong Netflix was kind of bugging out on us
when we were watching yeah a little bit I
mean
right there yeah but I thought sometimes the
subtitles his name was Ram it was the actor's
name oh yeah that's what it says on IMDb but
in the subtitle sometimes it said RAM on the
subtitles that's weird Netflix is tripping
Netflix was was bugging out on us while we're
watching I'm like well there's only so much
we can do because Netflix is wrong I think
they I mean let me just type this RR character
names let me just look here let me just look
here um of course they don't have his name
the one guy's name I'm looking for right now
is the one not the name not listed right now
Rama Rama right
that's what was confusing me sometimes the
subtitle said that because the subtitles couldn't
be contained by the sheer epicness of the
movie that it got confused that's the only
logical explanation for why it would mix things
up because it was like oh it's amazing but
look right here what uh uh Sita Rama raju's
fiancee
no I'm saying they're like maybe that was
like his I don't know it's weird that it would
have one no it's the same characters yeah
I'm a little bit confused
Beyonce but it's not in his his actual like
legal name I suppose it was using a fake name
when he was in the British uh I don't know
we picked up on the main things we did that's
the main thing that matters uh Rama Raju I
think it's I think that's his name Rama so
yeah with Rama like his character portrayal
I thought was great because it is such an
at odds and it is that kind of relatable story
of the detective who goes so far undercover
that he loses sight of everything and has
to get nasty and dirty but beyond that you
know it's someone who like I love the goal
at hand was he had to go that far into the
into the the depths of it all and or and no
matter what went in his way nothing nothing
could get in the way of that and he had to
provide guns for his villagers put a weapon
in front of it for his whole all his people
and uh watching that Journey that it's not
worth sacrificing certain it's not worth sacrificing
people though for it you know and this and
like their friendship mattered above all there's
also like a really fun movie and cool like
it's kind of crazy because people talk so
much about how gnarly of an experience this
movie was and it is an experience but I feel
like not enough people talk about like no
it's an actual story it's a real movie with
a real plot and real characters yeah and a
real journey and real themes and real life
subjects they're dealing with and everyone
just talks about like the there's like there's
not it's not the action stands out but I wouldn't
say out of three hours it's like a lot of
action I think the character stuff stands
out more than the action in my opinion I think
maybe they're about on par I think the coolest
thing about the movie for me is the fact that
it is able to have this crazy wild action
yet when it's happening even though it's ridiculous
you still buy into the stakes of what they're
doing yeah and you still care and you're still
rooting for them because you've invested so
much time with them when when the movie is
grounded that by the time things are going
bananas you're just you're just cheering or
you're having high emotional reactions because
we really didn't want to see them fight when
they when they stormed the the British Castle
or whatever and you really didn't want to
see them come to head when he was when he
was whipping him you know and I thought that
was a powerful scene watching him kind of
sing the song and like not bending the knee
in front of all the people and inspiring them
I was like man like we need to see like some
of that stuff in more movies it kind of reminded
even though it's it's the opposite side of
the world like some of their aspects of it
that reminded me of like American slavery
and and like obviously the whipping and like
the knee and other aspects surrender me of
Jesus you know uh like inspiring people and
like being like the Martyr to get the people
to revolt and I think that it's it's cool
that both of them had this goal to do it but
but neither of them saw it and they end in
some ways there was like this this unspoken
kinship before they knew each other's intentions
and maybe that was part of what bonded them
because they sensed each other's each other's
Souls you know and I think that yeah the movie
really demonstrates a lot of cool callbacks
and symbolisms like the whole necklace thing
like they each they each had to reveal a realization
when they saw the necklaces on each other's
person and yeah and yeah it was just a lot
of really cool stuff the music really really
worked for me my music was brilliant brilliant
it really drove to help Drive The Narrative
that much further well I think like you know
uh one represents fire and one represents
water and you and they are such opposites
that Clash but the whole point is that you're
supposed to be a blend of both together yeah
and it's kind of like the movie Inside Out
can't have uh can't have joy without sadness
you know just watched it it's fresh I know
so everything's gonna relate to inside out
for the next six months now okay I definitely
see and see what you mean about everything
ever all at once because it did have a lot
of those elements to it as well you know the
balance of Comedy the balance of drama the
balance of action the the Celebration The
Whimsy of it all the comedy yeah yeah cartoonish
nature yeah it's just a well-balanced film
a well-balanced breakfast I'm full I feel
I feel good after watching it and the guy
plays Raja man I thought he was freaking brilliant
both of them are great yeah they're both great
the Raja guy though it's like he's he just
has that they both command the screen but
he commands the screen I mean he got the more
I think he got the more interesting character
you know like it's the one with the real conflict
and the real like messed up past you know
that's it was crazy watching his whole family
die yeah and sacrifice his father and like
and that like that's like a core wound memory
I can say that it's a core remember for uh
of like not don't let anything get in the
way like that he was at that moment that that's
the moment that defined him and the journey
that he put on and he had to learn along the
way like maybe you shouldn't operate like
this since yeah you know um but yeah I thought
it was beautiful I think there's a lot of
beautiful things about it and I think the
the way this movie's composed overall like
it's really well thought out and calculated
in the symmetry of the shots like the the
editing of this it just seems like a nightmare
to me to try to put this movie together I'm
like this seems like a vast headache because
as much there's like crazy visual effects
with like the animals and you know certain
other key moments that look beautiful I really
liked how how much of the production design
felt like oh you got real extras here you
got real like weapons here you got real costumes
you know like you got real set pieces I thought
that was great to bring it all to life too
to mix it with the with the CGI that way it
feels more attainable and I think that's what
helps have something that's heightened but
believable when you when you mash the two
together so I thought it was gorgeous to look
at and it just made for a really interesting
experience and then unlike any other movie
I've seen so sorry I've put it off for so
long but here we are Merry Christmas made
it Merry Christmas Merry Christmas it's a
universal time for a lot of us here and um
yeah I'm not sure if there's I think we did
it I think we did I think we talked about
the main things we wanted to mention here
checked all the boxes it was fun great stuff
everything was great everything was great
maybe the women characters could have been
fleshed out a little bit more we could have
got more Jenny could have got more of um
yeah I think it's her name both of them we
need more both of them I mean I like them
I thought they were good but I don't know
the movies it was about the two guys thought
of romance Brotherhood this is good let's
go oh and the Ray Stevenson was a good villain
too he really I think him being the the bait
the main Baddie was um a good call because
he had that right level of he wasn't too over
the top but it was like just cheeky enough
and the wife was like she was like devious
oh she's the worst she's the worst she's the
villain she was like he wouldn't have done
half the things he did if it wasn't it's the
woman's problem it's the woman's fault why
the man messed up was this world coming to
since this is the 1800s woman a big good strolling
man or 1900s 19 with eight hours nine this
could be 1900 it could be like before World
War II a little bit before 1920s that's right
here 1920 1920. okay yeah all right we figured
that out of that right before this video alrighty
guys well thank you for being here be sure
to uh subscribe click that Bell leave a like
what did you think of RR um last but not least
Aaron I wanted to do a pick
Brandon Benzie hello hello it's a friend Aaron
here I'm here to tell you thanks for being
a great Patron you know I know this guy isn't
giving enough love you know I haven't given
you enough love I didn't even know you existed
until like four seconds ago but I just want
to say you were loved and you were appreciated
and buy yourself something nice this Christmas
you know get those sandals you always wanted
or that massage gun or that weighted blanket
you know you really want that weighted blanket
I want that weighted blanket you know maybe
if we can like split it somehow like I'll
send you some money and then you can like
ship it to me sometime anyway that's beside
the point uh we just want to thank you for
being a great Patron and for supporting the
channel and you're a superstar you're loved
and Greg's gonna get you a Christmas gift
personally this is the gift this is this is
the gift Aaron shouting you what you really
wanted when you pledge to this patreon for
a shout out was that Aaron shouts you out
I know I know he told me and I was like I'm
honored of course yeah I got you buddy I got
you we're gonna we're gonna make great things
happen next year enjoy those slippers I'm
gonna ask you I'm gonna ask you in a month
if you remember who we shouted out in RR if
you're like Brandon Benzie of course I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna give you five dollars okay
all right you heard that you heard that Ben
five dollars coming right Brian Benson you
heard that Brandon I mean Aaron what no refunds
Brennan Christmas
thank you they know in Austin Saturday thank
you Brandon for being you've been for a part
of our page for uh like a good amount of time
already like uh most of 2022 so thank you
and thank you for helping us in 2022 on a
strong note buddy Merry Christmas Happy New
Year
thank you